- Good morning, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is "believe,"
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is "solve big problems."
Over to you, Jack Ma.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
- We are not a company
that normally China call.
We call ourselves a
company running a platform.
A company that is running an ecosystem.
We are almost everywhere.
People say, "Jack, you know
you're in the B2B, B2C,
"and you're calling C2B on a
finance and online payment,
"logistic, cloud computing,
you are everywhere."
Not because we are greedy,
not because we want to do it.
Because we have to do it.
If we cannot, if we do not do it,
China e-commerce in the
years will collapse.
I remember nine years ago,
when I started Alipay.
People say, "Jack, don't
touch the financing sector
"cause it's illegal, you may imprisoned."
And we thought to ourselves,
if we don't do it,
the China e-commerce will
always like a chat room.
Everybody say it's a good thing.
"I don't pay, you don't get the things."
So I say, "Well, put me in the prison.
"Let's make sure that Alipay,
the payment solution works."
And the people said the payment solution
is such a stupid idea,
it's an escort service.
I pay you, you hold the
money and you get the things.
You pay the money, if you don't get
the things you want, return the money.
They said, "It's a stupid product."
and I say, "As long as it
has solved the problem,
"I like stupid things, you know."
Let's make stupid things smart.
Keep on improving everyday.
Today, we have over 800 million people
registered using Alipay, that's the count.
And Alipay today solved
the e-commerce problem.
We are paying the electricity,
water bill, and even taxi.
And last week I went
to a vegetable market,
somebody say, "We accept Alipay."
(audience laughing)
Because they say, "Alipay,
they get the false money,
"and Alipay can solve that problem."
So, we are actually building
up an infrastructure of China.
It's hard to stay motivated
when you're solving small problems.
At least for me, I have a really hard time
staying motivated, staying engaged
if I see the problem as
really small and tiny.
I had a call yesterday with a YouTuber
who has a successful channel
but hasn't posted in almost a year,
and now she wants to get back on the horse
and keep posting more videos,
and she's so concerned about
what happens in that first video.
She has plan to make more videos
but all she's wrapped up in is
"What do I do with this first video?"
And it's important to figure out
what happens in that first
video, but much more important is
what's the consistent plan, right?
If you want to have success on YouTube
it's about making regular videos.
How are you going to get to weekly videos
and then multiple times
per week and then daily?
The long tail, the long term,
is so much more important
than what happens in
this one specific video,
because how many of your
subscribers are going to watch it,
it's just not as important.
So for me, I hate focusing
on the little things
when there's a much bigger
problem to focus on.
She really should be focusing on,
"Okay, I make a first video,
doesn't really matter."
Any single video I put up on my channel,
it doesn't really matter,
it doesn't really have a huge impact.
It's accumulation, it's
every single video.
So I want to focus on the big things,
I want to focus on the big problems.
I want to solve that and not
just this little tiny thing.
And so it's why I want to
help a billion entrepreneurs.
It's a motivating, an inspiring goal.
I like helping entrepreneurs one-on-one.
It gives me a lot great
personal joy and satisfaction,
but I want to have a big impact,
I know I can have a bigger impact,
if you have the ability,
you have the responsibility,
and so that wakes me up energized
and try to go out and do something.
When I'm coming here making
these videos for you,
I'm imagining that I'm
speaking to a million people.
And I hope this message gets through,
because I want to have a big impact.
And so when you work on big problems,
you're more motivated, I think
especially as entrepreneurs.
We want to do something bigger.
We have that mind to want to go out
and have that huge impact,
and so we hate working on
these tiny, small problems.
The flip side, though,
sometimes is it can be too big.
And I remember having
this, where I thought,
"Can I actually help a
billion entrepreneurs?
"Can I actually change the world?
"Like, it's a noble thing,
"but can I actually go out and do it?"
"And sometimes your goal can be too big.
And may even depend on
the day, to be honest.
Some days you wake up and you're motivated
and ready and go do it, and
some days you wake up and say,
"Who am I to be able to go off
"and have that big of an impact?"
And so it's finding where is
that edge of your comfort zone
What's goal that's big enough to push you,
to say, "That's just beyond achievable,
"if I push myself hard I
can go out and do that.
"I'm at the edge of my comfort zone."
Because if it's too easy,
you're not going to be
motivated to go out and do it.
You're going to be bored,
you're going to feel like
it's a waste of your time,
a waste of your talent,
you're not going to be engaged in it.
And if it's too big or too hard,
you're also not going
to be motivated to do it
because it's impossible and
it's never going to get done.
So find what that goal is at
the edge of your comfort zone,
solving a big problem
that is meaningful to you,
that is impactful to you,
that makes you feel valuable.
If you can go out and reach it
and solve it and help people,
I think that's really,
really, really important
as entrepreneurs.
And I'd be looking at yourself,
your life, your business,
if you don't feel challenged,
if you feel bored,
if you're not growing,
it's probably because
you are not solving a big
enough problem right now.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is the big
problem that you want to solve
right now with your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
really curious to find out,
and also if you're leaving a comment
within the first couple
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Paul-Benoit Duvoisin.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
And I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going ♫
- [Narrator] For Naveen, the
billionaire formula is simple.
- [Naveen] What makes a successful person?
They go out and solve big problems.
So you know how to make a billion dollars?
You solve a 10 billion dollar problem.
- [Narrator] Having
already made his billions,
he unashamedly wants to use
his business brain to change our world.
- Let's focus on education, healthcare,
energy, shortage of
water, shortage of food.
And I'm going to tell you how
innovation and entrepreneurship
can solve each of these problems.
Let's look at education.
Imagine if you're able
to use a $25 tablet,
and build some type of
game that is more effective
than a private tutor,
and is more addictive
than the most addictive video game.
Think about it, one day a child
is going to come to the mother and say,
"Mom, can I play just
one more hour of math?
"Because I enjoy it so much."
- [Narrator] Naveen has a knack
of putting people under his spell.
Making his mission to
solve some of mankind's
biggest problems seem plausible
in space and on Earth.
What if we can build an
artificial intelligence system
that can be used by a village girl?
She will be able to go door to door
and able to diagnose a disease
where there are no healthcare,
there's no hospitals,
there are no doctors.
- [Narrator] These are
big ideas that could turn
a big profit but some of
them seem a bit farfetched.
- [Naveen] What if you take
a 3D printer on the moon?
And somebody can go out and send
the DNA of a bacteria or a virus
and we print it right there and leave it
on the moon and watch it grow.
- [Interviewer] These ideas,
they're a bit out there,
aren't they, Naveen?
Don't people think you're just a bit mad?
- The point is that the
reason they think it's mad
because they don't know
it's already happening.
The things that used to be science fiction
are now becoming science reality.
- And I think that for all of you,
there are many areas where
there's leverage available in the world,
where one or two people with a good idea
and a lot of hard work can
really make a difference,
there's many many things like that,
and it's good not to forget that,
but it's good to look for those things.
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
And one of the things that surprised me,
that's a very broad mission,
that's a lot of work,
we're not going to achieve
it anytime soon, right.
It's almost an impossible task.
But it's an exciting task
and one that you can get
other people excited about,
and they can help you.
And one of the things
that also surprised me
is that sometimes easier to do something
that's harder because other
people get excited about it
and you can get much more resource.
You can get tremendous resources
to solve a hard problem
whereas you might only get minor resources
to solve a small problem.
- I like to say my management style
is problem-solver-in-chief.
And so what I do in a given day is
I have a set of problems
that need to be solved,
and I start at the most
important and work my way down.
And for the problems
I don't have time for,
somebody else gets to solve them.
If somebody's already solving a problem,
I don't need to get involved
if the problem's getting solved.
But people go, "Wow, so your
day's just full of problems."
I'm like, "Yeah, I got a lot of problems."
(audience chuckling)
But it's sort of like how
a math professor thinks of problems.
Think of a great math professor
who has no math problems to solve.
He's a very sad math professor.
(interviewer laughing)
And so, that's very much how I look at it.
Solving problems, every
problem is an opportunity
for innovating and being creative,
and finding something new.
And that's what I love to
do, and I do it every day.